[Musique]
les trottinettes tiers vont prendre
d'assaut un nouveau territoire yvelinois
après 50 ans en Yvelines ou encore la
vallée de Chevreuse c'est la communauté
d'agglomération Grand Paris sanéoise qui
va aller voir s'implanter 12 postes de
facteurs à pourvoir dans les Yvelines la
Poste lance une nouvelle campagne de
recrutement le but faire face au pic
d'activité au moment des fêtes de fin
d'année pour postuler la poste
recrute.fr ce weekend sonne la fin des
vacances scolaires de la Toussaint sur
la route le samedi est classé orange en
région parisienne pour les retours Bison
Futé conseil de rejoindre ou de
traverser l'île de France avant 14h tous
les feux sont au vert pour prendre la
route le dimanche 6 novembre pas de RER
C pour ce week-end les 5 et 6 novembre
la circulation des trains est
interrompue entre Viroflay rive gauche
et Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines la SNCF
invite à emprunter la ligne N pour
rejoindre ses gares le FC Versailles 78
va-t-il continuer sur sa belle lancée
vendredi 4 novembre le nouveau promus
affronte Châteauroux pour la 11e journée
de Nationale
au club Yves Linois est actuellement 3e
du classement Châteauroux et 4e j-3
avant le départ de la Route du Rhum
parmi les 138 skippers à tenter
l'aventure au solitaire de yvelin
Louis Burton sur son IMOCA Bureau Vallée
vise un top 5 le Versailles Bellion
prendra le départ de cette course sur
son IMOCA comme un seul homme power
Altavia le départ est donné le 6
novembre prochain à Saint-Malo